do you really believe that January 6 was
a peaceful protest would you really call
it that considering people breaching
police lines some people were armed
there were broken windows people wanted
to hang my pants why do you really
consider it a peaceful protest well I I
didn't call it a peaceful protest I
referred to the pro-life Advocates
outside of santangelo's abortion clinic
as peaceful protesters what I said of
the January excuse me January 6th
there's is that they were largely not
violent at all not one of them brought
any weapons there was no plan of
insurrection or anything like that and
the most uh
famous faces from that day were actually
escorted in by the Capitol Hill Police
and were given a private tour so much at
most of what we were told about that day
was just a flat out lie now this doesn't
mean that all of them or most of them
acted appropriately it doesn't mean that
they didn't commit some kind of
transgression I joke about them being
arrested for cracking a Coors Light in
the capital rotunda but I suppose you're
not supposed to crack a chorus light in
the capital rotunda and so there should
be some proportional sort of punishment
for that but there isn't and taken in
conjunction with the protest movement
so-called fiery but mostly peaceful
protest Movement we were told that took
place for the eight months before
January 6th when BLM and antifa burned
the country to the Grand coast to coast
and attacked Federal buildings by the
way and killed people and robbed and
looted and and murdered so many of those
people got off with Nary a slap on the
wrist meanwhile the horn hat guy who to
my knowledge didn't commit any actual
crime on that day was was in prison for
41 months that's just completely insane
and the only way to view it with any
sort of Sanity is to recognize that this
was the Biden Administration punishing
political dissidents you know when when
people when dissidents go to prison
sometimes they they're very smart about
it and they act in a way that is so
clear to the public that they didn't do
anything wrong you think of someone like
Martin Luther King or Gandhi maybe but
very often when dissidents are jailed
they have done something wrong and and
they're jailed not on no grounds but on
extremely trumped-up charges
and uh I think that's what we're seeing
here we're seeing extraordinarily
absurdly trumped-up charges for the
January 6 people or even more so for the
the peaceful pro-life demonstrators
outside of santangelo's facility and
you're seeing people who have actually
committed heinous crimes being let off
with a slap on the wrist this is why
Martin Luther King popularized that that
line uh Injustice anywhere as a threat
to Justice everywhere and it's a true
line that's very important you know
Justice is a habit of the will habit of
virtue that inclines our will to render
to God that which he deserves that would
that would be religion broadly which is
the highest form of Justice and Justice
applied to everybody would be would be
giving people what they deserve and so
when you have two tiers of Justice you
don't have Justice at all
just a a follow-up question going back
to the Horn Guy
um so you're saying that he got a little
over three years in prison he broke into
the capital and he was escorted around
the capital by Capitol Hill Police he
wasn't escorted he was it's on video
Lucas um so are you saying that if this
was antifa as a lot of right-wingers
were claiming it was in the early days
before it became very obvious that these
were Trump supporters are you saying
that if antifa broke into the capital in
the exact same way you would downplay it
in the same way you're downplaying I
don't think I'm down playing anything I
think I'm seeing things clearly and
stating my opinion which happens to be
correct If This Were antifa if this were
antifa they would have brought bombs
which they did when I spoke at the
University of Pittsburgh just about six
months ago if this were antifa they
would have maimed people and probably
killed some of them but that didn't
happen with the January sisters the only
person who died in the political
violence of January 6th was one of the
January sixthors who was murdered by a
trigger happy cop that this is contrary
to what we were told by the media but
the media lied to us and and then the
the so-called January Sixers who may
have behaved in an improper way I'm not
suggesting they they didn't were
sentenced to years in prison over crimes
that should have received a slap on the
wrist meanwhile people who committed
heinous crimes for months were were
given a slap on the wrist when they
should still be in prison today
[Applause]
and the last question you were
addressing
you were you were addressing
directionality and how right now America
isn't at the point where China is but
we're going in that direction do you
think that talking about breaching the
capital as though it's an everyday thing
and it's you know improper but it's not
worth three years in prison let alone 30
years for treason do you think that's
taking us in a bad Direction I suppose
the question would have to be what do
you mean by breaching the capital if
you're talking about the horn hat guy he
was escorted around he he didn't breach
anything he was he was escorted by the
police
and so if you're asking me is it is it
good to make a nuisance of yourself in
the capital no I don't think it is and I
think that it ought to be punished in a
way that is in proportion to the
transgressions that we're committed but
I think according to most people first
of all they believe that the January 6th
people killed people they committed all
that sorts of acts of violence that day
that did not happen but they believed
that they committed an Insurrection
tried to run a coup d'etat the horn hat
guy was standing there on the floor he
could have taken over the country but
they didn't have an alternate
Constitution to put in and as I
mentioned none of them had any weapons
Not only was the the January 6th
incident not the worst Insurrection in
the history of the United States it
wasn't the worst attack in the history
of the U.S capital not even close it
wasn't even in the top half dozen as I
mentioned earlier the the capital has
been blown up on multiple occasions as I
mentioned earlier in in the 1950s Puerto
nationalists broke into the capital and
started shooting congressmen five of
them were injured in that and what
happened later on to those people Jimmy
Carter liberal darling let them off the
hook what happened to the Weather
Underground when they came in it blew up
the capital blew a part of the capital
well Bel Air is basically got off the
hook for his involvement with whether
undergrad it went on to become a mentor
to Barack Obama what happened to the
half dozen mostly left-wing attacks
we don't even remember them people think
that the the January 6th lectern guy
smiling with Pelosi's Podium what was
the The gravest Assault on the capitol
it's it's a farce and and it has made a
farce out of our criminal justice system
to see it treated in this way I've found
your marks very thoughtful but I did
have a problem so at the risk of
paraphrasing you describe Liberty as the
ability to conform more closely to the
will of God you describe the
government's provision of choice on
matters of contraception abortion at
least for adults as an attack on Liberty
as you define it you found it important
to remark that Joe Biden the president
acts against his private Faith as a
Catholic and supportive abortion
contraception what not so my question is
do you not find it important to separate
church and state what is your view on
the public atheist and the private
practicer not only do I not find it
important I don't find it possible I
don't see any way that one could
separate Church from State it's never
happened ever in the history of archives
or any other country foreign
the unfortunate phrase in our national
context comes from the private writing
of Thomas Jefferson you won't find it
anywhere in the Constitution or the
Declaration of Independence the
Constitution provides in the first
amendment that there will be no
established church at the federal level
uh the reason for that is not because
they wanted the country to be atheist
but because there were already
established churches at the state level
which persisted for decades after
ratification John Adams was clear about
this he famously said that the country
the Constitution is only Built for
immoral and religious people which was
not just soft soap and a nice little
sentimental quote that that is just a
fact about how the Constitution works
and how free people can can operate John
Jay said much the same thing so many of
the founding fathers said the same thing
uh the other reason why you you can't
separate Church from state is that uh
any law
presupposes a religious view because all
law ultimately refer to the moral law
and the moral law has recourse to
religion I mentioned earlier what
religion is religion is a habit of
virtue that inclines the will to render
to God what God deserves that's all it
is and so if we're going to pass a law
about abortion then we we need to make
some moral argument uh for instance it's
bad to slaughter babies would be I think
the good argument and the weak argument
is women should be able to do whatever
they want and sleep with terrible men I
don't think that's very convincing but
that's the argument that the libs make
and it's a moral argument too and you
you battle those out and you see which
one has the stronger moral reasoning but
this is true even if you're talking
about laws about parking tickets
even if you're talking about the
marginal corporate tax rate ultimately
you must make moral arguments and we
can't avoid politics obviously we're
talking about government we're standing
here in the nation's capital we can't
avoid politics because man is not an
island entire under himself man is the
social creature and the political animal
we are meant to live together and at the
most fundamental level we're we're
coupling creatures so men are for women
in families which is the Bedrock of
society and the rest of society Springs
up from that uh so so we can't avoid
that question and we are made in the
image and likeness of God whether we
want to admit it or not you know I have
no problem with our atheist friends I
was an atheist myself for 10 years so I
have a great deal of sympathy but there
are delusions
do not contradict the way that societies
have always worked for all of human
history or rather they don't they don't
uh mean that we have to upend the way
that Society really works man being made
in the image and likeness of God will
find his true end only in God the very
fact that we can speak intelligibly and
you can understand what I'm saying and
vice versa by these symbols that are
coming out of our clouds that refer to
some objective reality outside of us is
because the universe is intelligible
because it was created by an
intelligence and so you know if if you
want to have a flourishing country you
have to presuppose that God exists
that's what our founding fathers did
even the most liberal among them Thomas
Jefferson was kind of the lib of the
founding fathers but don't forget in in
the Declaration of Independence he says
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and
endowed by our creator with certain
unalienable rights of the country
presupposes the existence of God thank
God that that is the case or the country
would not have lasted two weeks and as
our country turns away from God you see
those institutions crumbling because
John Adams was right and the Reddit tier
atheists who insist that we throw out
the entirety of accumulated wisdom from
all of human history are unsurprisingly
not right